I am very excited to talk about this
because we do a lot of stuff on this
show that all the crazy [ __ ] that's in
our foods all the whacked-out chemicals
that are in yoga mats that you're eating
and pink slime and everything else and
every time we do one of these stories
the comments section go crazy and they
yell at me and they say I'm anti science
because I'm even bringing this up and
it's in there and it's not gonna kill
you that seems to be a general theme I
think it's weird that we be ver anal
gland juice is vanilla flavoring I think
that's weird I know it may not kill me I
just think it's odd that someone was
squeezing a bieber's anus and thought
this tastes good so I wanted to bring on
people that understand a little more
about science than I do and break some
of this stuff down because you might
have heard this week that coca-cola has
announced that it's not going to use
brominated vegetable oil or B vo in soft
drinks such as Fanta fresca and Powerade
anymore and this comes after a lot of
people were talking online about how bbo
is related to compounds that are found
in fire retardants so let's look at a
little more info on BB oh it contains
the chemical bromine which is also found
in fire retardants as I just said small
quantities of BB o are legally allowed
in some drinks to ensure even flavor
distribution according to the Center for
Science in the Public Interest B vo is a
poorly tested and possibly dangerous
food additive and there's no reason to
use it in Gatorade or other drinks so
before we get to the next thing I want
to stop there for a second because as I
said when we do this everyone yells at
me they say well if you don't eat a ton
of it you'll be okay we put chemicals in
our body all the time and everything has
chemicals and the ink has these getting
chemicals in you're scared and you're
made of chemicals and your makeup goes
and all of that right and all of that so
can you guys give me just sort of a
basic break something can you give me
something to pick this conversation off
so I'll start by saying that I think
that the people in the comment section
there's a lot of validity to what
they're saying because there is
especially in liberal media there is
kind of a quick tick to immediately be
afraid of anything that corporation
produces and immediately it be afraid of
words like molecules like chemical and
and you know and then all of a sudden it
sounds dangerous we have this debate all
the time with genetically modified
organisms we have this debate we
you know preservatives food additives or
whatever yeah so there is there is a
reason to kind of stop sit back and
think about this rationally okay I'm on
board so so we'll start there now I
personally don't know much about BVO as
a food additive but when organizations
that are there to protect the public
interest or do their research and do
their due diligence and say okay we
don't know much about this
there are many nations that have banned
it now that's not reason enough for us
to you but here's the clincher for me
there's no reason for it to be there
because you can have the same effect if
you use something that's been proven to
be safe right why aren't we using the
thing that's been proven to be safe I
mean you think it might have something
to do with money yeah do you think
possibly it could be a financial
decision probably and this is the cool
thing I think about living in the
Internet age is that if enough people
get wind of an issue and write a
petition and get loud about it and say
I'm not gonna buy your product anymore
because I'm afraid if this one thing
that you're using in it that I don't
think has been clearly tested and I'm
not sure about the health benefits of it
we'll just stop buying coca-cola
products coca-cola has to respond they
see a drop in product and then make
their product better even if it's not
killing us they can make it more natural
and that's probably basically is it fair
to say that things that are natural are
basically good none that I want to get
into the economic argument yet
everything is natural yeah yeah it
occurs in nature it's natural I don't
want I hate to be that picky but I know
that everybody's gonna say no please no
but I mean it's true and the thing is
it's good to find things that you think
are unhealthy point them out and replace
them with something that's better
especially if that thing that's better
is available I don't know why I like you
said we're not already using that to
begin with but but there's a lot of
people out there who like to think about
these things
and they freaked out about it because
they want to be like I'm
health-conscious I'm gonna you know I'm
gonna take this initiative and do better
with this issue but they're ignoring
everything else like they're ignoring
the ammonia that people use to disinfect
meat they're ignoring all the hormones
with you I mean yeah I mean there's just
so many things out there that are
exponentially worse but nobody cares
about but they hop onto this one issue
and feel better about themselves as a
whole because they're taking care of one
tiny
little detail okay so just to talk about
the pink sign for one second it gets
because it gets everybody nuts and we've
got a couple videos on it so basically
they're taking the worst of the worst
meat stuff literally that's falling on
the floor then they pile it all together
they wash it with ammonia you were not
kidding they wash it with ammonia to
kill all the horrible stuff that's on
there and then we eat it and it is
edible
it is human before they do that process
it's not even fit for human consumption
the meat and then and then it is but
when we've done videos on that even then
people say well they've done what
they're supposed to do so it's okay but
you wouldn't you would not agree with
that no I wouldn't eat stuff that was
washed with bleach either I mean it
doesn't matter what they've done to it
to disinfect it it's still really
unhealthy not to mention all the
hormones and stuff that you find and
meat right it's just I mean really bad
for you I take a really nuanced approach
to like specifically if we're talking
about pink slime because let's say that
I am living in the inner city and I
don't have the monetary means to eat at
Whole Foods and I don't have the means
to grow my own food I mean hopefully I
like the idea of getting back to a slow
food movement I like the idea of getting
back to once you can get to the source
of your food if there's fewer steps that
it takes before that makes it to your
mouth it's more likely I think generally
speaking I'm not gonna say as a rule but
generally speaking it's more likely that
that food will be healthier the less
processed it gets the more process it
gets that the the more we get into this
conversation about food that weirdly
kind of paradoxically makes us obese but
also makes us malnourished and that's a
huge problem in in this country
specifically but also it's going into
other Western nations so when you but
when you say if something is more
natural it's probably better for you
that's [ __ ] because like you can't
eat [ __ ] this is like yeah like you
can't just like go out and eat some
house [ __ ] like that's natural and it'll
make you really sick you can there are
certain things that we talked about that
first step are horribly dangerous you
know there's toxic things all over the
place in nature and chemic chemical to
extract things and to to add things
together in such a way that they take
natural ingredients and make powerful
drugs out of them and make powerful
substances and may
food use food science to make things
that taste better and that are whatever
and so I think the issue is as you
always like to say and this is an
important point
follow the money like what is the goal
here is the goal feeding people and and
feeding them nutritious food or is the
goal you know a multinational
corporations profit motive coca-cola and
I'm the first to admit I love coca-cola
and I drink and [ __ ] every day it's
like my biggest vice it's horrible for
you that's the broad a big-ass coca-cola
I drink I think I do
alright it's like I don't drink alcohol
I don't smoke I don't do draw that's my
advice like that is my advice but it's
not good for you like in no sense of the
term is drinking a coke something that
you need for like basic nutrition high
fructose corn seed for you it causes all
sorts of health problems like liver
problems and diabetes like your body
shouldn't take in much sugar yeah so
what we're talking about here is are
these corporations making decisions in
the best interest of your health
probably not they're probably making
decisions in the best interest of their
profits as you mentioned so we need
legislation we need regulation that
protects the consumer but we also
shouldn't be so trigger-happy that every
time we hear the word chemical it makes
us shake in our boots because everything
is made of okay so speaking of the
corporation so the the big thing that
kicked this off a couple months ago was
the subway thing that we've alluded to
and the chemical that is in the bread or
was in the bread because they've now
taken out it's called a da and let's get
some more info about a da its primary
uses in plastic and rubber products like
yoga mats and flip-flops where it's used
to make them softer and more stretchy so
if you wonder why the bread at Subway is
so fluffy and stretchy you think maybe
at a time do with that many bread
products often contain a da which is
used to make dough more elastic and a da
is known to increase the risk of asthma
allergies and skin problems and we've
got a list a bunch of foods that
actually contain a da McDonald's buns
chick-fil-a sandwiches Burger King buns
Dunkin Donuts Wendy's bread Arby's
jagged ice called you I mean everything
pretty much everything I don't see you
in and out on there which is nice so how
should we fear this because this this
one seems a little more close to home to
me because you can sort of like really
see why the breads you don't mean you
get bread if you get regular you go to a
bakery and get a bread it's not as
fluffy and stretchy so there is some
connection between the rubbery feeling
of a yoga mat and this bread so can I at
least make that very separate in our
minds like just because it has one
component doesn't mean we're eating yoga
mats like I think that that is the thing
we immediately jump to it's like okay
this chemical is found in these two
products so therefore these two products
are the same thing yeah and so no we are
not eating yoga mats like let's get that
clear we take that jump a little bit
more with this one we don't know if
those quantities and there were harmful
I don't think there's enough research
but again if you can make it without the
damn thing yeah and it's and there's
even a chance that it's more healthy for
the consumer then there you go that's a
great idea
I mean why not and I do like that the
power of the consumers collective voice
made a change for subway because subway
tries to tell themselves as a more
healthy alternative and they don't want
to have things in their food that are
gonna make health-conscious consumers
turn away but if you're really that
concerned about it the first option
would be don't eat fast food I mean is
that really the end that like you can at
least get that out that's what I've been
thinking this whole time like I don't
want to say you shouldn't fix a problem
that exists because if you can use
something healthier then use it but at
the same time you're freaking out over
one chemical whenever you're eating
McDonald's hamburger think about what
you're eating how gross it is and all
the crap that's in there and you're
freaking out about a DA like it just
seems a little bit and also I know the
people will make the economic argument
that you talked about before and they'll
say they're not they don't have access
to this other food and things of that
nature but I do think that you know you
could buy a can of tuna for a dollar 50
and yet still probably die of mercury
poisoning is my mom reminds but like
there are some cheaper ways to eat
things and I know it's not as quick as
McDonald's but there are ways so it's
not totally tied into the deck is
stacked against you my advice is never
throw up your hands and just give up
right yes this deck is stacked against
you and unfortunately you're going to
see people in certain economic
situations having less options and it's
going to be harder to make healthy
decisions and so yes that [ __ ] sucks
and it's unfair and I think we should be
pushing to have more healthy
grocery options in lower-income
neighborhoods I'm not saying that it the
option or the best option is just
[ __ ] eat McDonald's and cry about it
like obviously fast-food is not healthy
like Point Blank it's just not healthy
to eat fast food and as you said why are
we nitpicking about this one thing when
there's a million other reasons that
fast food is not healthy yes
opt for healthier options but let's all
keep in mind as we're sitting here in
our comfy chairs in West Hollywood that
some people don't have the options that
we have so we should at least maintain
perspective about that technically we're
in Culver City which we are I quite as
nice as well people would know that I
tried to use something that they could
reference